The Queen of the Lioness decided to make the elections in her kingdom fairer.
At the moment he has his citizens divided into groups, each of which selects one representative,
who will then sit in the council that constitutes laws for the kingdom of the jungle.
But the citizens are dissatisfied and it is easy to see why: the council is full of monkeys.
Of course, some citizens are monkeys, but not all. This advice
it does not represent the kingdom fairly.
Therefore, the Queen of the Lioness will visit one of the electoral groups to find out how to correct the problem.
There are five monkeys in the group, four tigers, three owls, two lynxes and one bison.
One stands for each and the other citizens choose their own kind.
The rule of choice is that the candidate with the most votes wins, which is a monkey.
But this is a very unsatisfactory result, as 2/3 of citizens in this group * are not *
monkeys and monkeys would not vote.
Likewise, across all the other groups in the kingdom, monkeys have more votes
than anyone else, so they win elections, even if they are a minority of the overall population.
A closer survey will reveal that independent counselors hired to set boundaries between groups
first and foremost, they weren't as independent as they seem at first sight.
The result is dissatisfied citizens who do not trust the jungle council to make for everyone
creating laws, quite rightly.
The queen of lion's goal is to maximize the number of satisfied citizens after the election.
One solution is to cancel electoral groups and use a proportional system ... However, her
citizens * want * to have a local representative.
So the queen needs a system that will satisfy the maximum of citizens by taking advice, while
maintain local, regional elections.
After a short survey, he finds a solution to the problem: one portable voice system.
His big change is that the election groups send more than one representative, which is
it may seem strange, but the queen decides to try it: she takes the three groups she used to do
they chose one deputy, and join them into one larger one that chooses three.
On election day, citizens cast votes and results in this new group are exactly the same
as before: 34% for monkey, 33% for owl and 33% for lynx.
But now he doesn't win the most votes: to get the winner, we'll take all the votes
and divide them by the necessary number of representatives, in our case three, which gives 33% as
the threshold needed for election.
So * all three * candidates will go to the board - which exactly reflects the will of the voters
in the group.
While with the old system, each group would choose a monkey and leave 2/3 of the citizens
without proper representation. The larger group with multiple representatives allows the group to be more
Proportional.
This test went well, but it was also the simplest maybe - the queen now wants to see
how the election goes, in which not everyone wins.
Another big group to try is five candidates: gorilla, tarsi, monkey,
tiger and lynx, three of whom may be representatives.
The election day took place and here are the results of the citizens' vote:
gorilla has 5% gorilla has 28%
monkey has 33% tiger has 21%
feature has 13%
The candidate needs 33% to vote, as last time. The monkey has so much and is therefore immediately
elected one of three representatives.
But no one else has achieved 33%, so how are the remaining two representatives selected?
Step One: Get rid of the candidate with the least votes. Sorry tarsier - you really didn't have a chance.
When citizens voted, they could just tick off their favorite candidate, but
with a portable voice they also have the opportunity to rate candidates. This is important because
we will learn how the elections would have ended if one of the candidates were missing.
A small and frightened tarsier would give his voice a large calm gorilla if the tarsier was not among them
candidates. So if their candidate doesn't win, they want to put their gorilla voices instead.
This will move the gorilla to 33% and it will become the next elected representative.
Valuation allows citizens to support their favorite candidates without worry - no sense
speculate how others will vote. The system works to maximize
satisfaction of voters with results.
Back to the group: there is still one representative to choose, so the next one will be a feature.
His voters don't like monkeys, but he thinks that tiger intentions are similar to their intentions,
and therefore when a feature cannot win, they want to give the tiger a vote. The tiger gets 33% and becomes
third and last elected representative.
Election results look fairly good, especially if they take into account the first * and * second choice of citizens.
More citizens now have a local representative that they can easily contact while the old system
everyone would have a monkey.
The Queen still wants to know what happens in a group with only two political parties.
More candidates of the same party would be a disaster with a "majority vote wins" system:
they would divide their voters and give the victory to the candidate.
The queen will try out the last group with 2/3 tigers and 1/3 gorillas and as before
needs three representatives.
Because with a portable voice, citizens evaluate their candidates, there may be more candidates
same sides without problems.
Tigers have two candidates as well as gorillas.
The white tiger is elected first representative, but what next? Though the tiger seems to have now
least votes, it is also clear that he would have a lot more votes if he was not in the elections
A white tiger. If a candidate has more votes than he needs, like a white tiger,
first, the excess voices are passed to his second alternative. This gives the tiger 33%
and becomes another elected representative.
If it seems strange, there are two things to consider:
1) If the excess voices were ignored and the tiger removed, the gorillas would then
they had two remaining seats, which would obviously not represent the group.
2) Ignoring these excess voices means punishing citizens who have insured
a popular candidate, which makes them think how others choose, rather than what they want.
If the candidate gets extra votes, then first of all means his voters
they make up a large proportion of the citizens and should thus gain more
representatives.
As soon as the tiger's voices are handed over, the election will be completed last time: the gorilla
it was the last one to be eliminated and the other alternative to its voters is the younger candidate, so
the gorilla gets a place. And the results are fair.
The Queen of the Lioness saw that the portable voice was working. Let the groups have one or more
parties, the process is the same:
1. Citizens rate their candidates. 2. Candidates above the threshold will win immediately.
3. Extra voices shall be transmitted to the second alternative.
4. If there is no winner, the last candidate is eliminated, and his votes go second.
5. Repeat until we have all the winners.
This whole process is designed to maximize the number of voters satisfied
with results.
This process gives the portable voice many advantages over the old "most votes win":
1. Citizens can sincerely vote for their favorite candidates without speculation about others' choices.
2. It is more proportional. So monkey games
with borders. 3. Almost all citizens will have a local representative
whom they actually voted.
The Queen of the Lioness finally decided to switch to a system of one portable voice,
to provide better jungle advice for everyone.